c'est
un quartier pauvre des rues ensablées
des jeunes qui rêve d'une autre vie
en poussant un ballon rond qui nous tous
en sandales de plastique
cette scène pourrait avoir été filmée
mais partout en afrique
ici nous sommes à yopougon devant la
maison où eni titi drogba d'ivoire y est
le plus célèbre au monde
la veuve en elle-même fait c'est moi
c'est là et avait la prophétie dont nous
on habitait palissy donc il a grandi
silva grandissent monsieur drogba avait
fait bâtir cette petite maison près de
la banque où il travaillait didier
courent après le ballon
dès ses premiers pas didier il est tombé
du premier étage et jusqu'en bas ben
c'est comme si il n'avait rien et si
lever son ballon à un an le petit didier
trenet son ballot partout mais sa maman
ne souhaitait pas qu'il poursuive sa
passion pour nous jouer au foot cesse
c'est l'enfant qui n'a pas réussi en
fait même quand on a faim on va jouer au
foot on lui dit mais attends tu perds
ton temps à faire 51 vient travailler au
mois de l'année des frappes et du tfue
les bras voilà michel goba l'oncle de
didier a joué comme professionnel en
france où il a vécu 30 ans il revient
dans son pays formé de jeunes talents
elle a mis la barre très haute
quand michel goba jouer en europe
c'était lui le héros de la famille
didier part vivre en france avec son
oncle à l'âge de 5 ans
son père y voit l'occasion de lui offrir
de bonnes études à nous pour moi il est
parti en france pour apprendre faut être
un médecin avocat encore apprendre à
aller à l'école
et puis réussit sa vie mais aujourd'hui
c'est déjà ma tournée hélas non ils
avaient tous les mois je n'avais pas
indiqué pat en france ça m'en vais
sade est dure comme les 6 ha bah oui
très dur ça mon fils et je n'ai là et
puis du coup il faut qu'on se sait pas
non plus quand l'hôte est là elle est
venue le prendre comme saddam mais alors
là c'est la fin de ce déracinement
bouleverse le jeune ivoirien échanges le
cours de sa vie en france didier suis
rapidement les traces de son oncle le
footballeur en drogba devient
professionnel il attire rapidement
l'attention des grands clubs
en 2003 il réalise son rêve de jouer
pour l'olympique de marseille
mais après une seule saison l'om revend
son joueur vedette pour 37 millions
d'euros
trencontre kiss-in à chelsea et que
l'unité sont à deux doigts
l'attaquant n'a pas envie d'aller jouer
et vivre en grande bretagne mais c'est
avec le club de chelsea qui ne deviendra
une star planétaire
il sourit
drogba joue en europe pour gagner sa vie
en côte d'ivoire c'est pour l'honneur
qu'il joue pas sur l'autre il dispute
son premier match avec l'équipe
nationale le 8 septembre 2002 dix jours
plus tard la guerre éclate des rebelles
tentent de renverser le gouvernement
le coup d'état raté plongent le pays en
crise
deux clans politiques s'arrachent le
pouvoir et coupe le pays en deux les
rebelles ont la mainmise sur le nord une
région pauvre où les musulmans sont
majoritaires le gouvernement gbagbo
contrôlent le sud plus chrétien est plus
développée la fondation pourrait le
faire aller lobognon était ministre des
sports jusqu'à l'an dernier durant la
guerre c'était le porte parole des
forces rebelles dans le nord après deux
coups de feu les ivoiriens se retrouvent
à nouveau la télévision donc derrière
leur équipe nationale en train de
jubiler didier drogba est donc c'était
soit d'une paix cet espoir de voile et
ivoire est rassemblé
en 2005 drogba même l'équipe ivoirienne
à sa première qualification en coupe du
monde un événement historique pour la
côte d'ivoire
le capitaine des éléphants profitent de
l'émotion pour lancer un appel à la paix
s'il vous plaît déposer tous les armes
fait les élections organisées les
élections et tout sera dit mieux on veut
s'amuser
la côte d'ivoire poule après avoir
participé à la coupe du monde mais
c'était quelque chose d'énorme non
blaise kouassi est une amie de drogba
depuis qu'ils ont joué ensemble en
bretagne il y à 14 ans ce jour-là à
khartoum
le défenseur s'est agenouillé avec les
autres joueurs
le message qu'on s'est réuni pour
pouvoir faire passer par didier parce
que c'est lui qui parlait parce que
c'est lui le capitaine parce que c'est
lui l'élu 2 mais c'était quelque chose
défaut ça venait des nuits en plus ça
venait du fond du coeur au lendemain de
chaque victoire les joueurs sont écrits
à abidjan par des centaines de milliers
de partisans
à
tous rêvent déjà fait qu'elle est voilée
dans sur l'équipe nationale en plus de
jouer ce soir c'est inexplicable les
moments qu'on vit même à vous raconter
j'ai révisé moment et j'ai des frissons
les succès des éléphants injuste comme
un baume sur les plaies vives mais
didier drogba ne se contente pas de
hockey vue il exploite sa notoriété pour
ouvrir une brèche dans le mur qui coupe
le pays en deux
allez présenter
quand l'ivoirien reçoit le trophée du
meilleur footballeur africain
il va le présenter à moi qu'est le fief
des rebelles
drogba donne même l'accolade au chef des
rebelles guillaume soro qui sera le
lendemain
nommé premier ministre d'un gouvernement
de coalition nationale
je vois encore les soldats a fait des
coupes pour porter didier drogba donc il
ne cherchait pas à porter une arme ni
cherché à empêcher le trophée et à
prendre des photos avec des drogba le
capitaine pousse l'audace d'un cran il
insiste pour qu'un match de l'équipe
nationale soit jouée en plein territoire
rebelle obliger tout le monde à partir à
bouaké
voici ce tome 1 il ya beaucoup de son
parti c'était le stade était plein et
comment vous êtes senti que j'avais peur
ça j'avais peur monsieur drogba et les
autres dignitaires quittent le stade
avant la fin du match car les forces de
sécurité craignent une attaque quand
didier marque le cinquième et dernier
but l'afo écrite tellement fort que son
père qui est en train de s'éloigner du
stade pense au pire
moi je ne sais pas si c'est la guerre
qui a commencé comme quoi n'en dénombre
que délicat boîte et drogba ne joue plus
pour l'équipe nationale n'est plus un
des footballeurs les mieux payés de la
planète mais son étoile brille toujours
dans les yeux de millions d'ivoiriens
qui continue de suivre ses performances
à distance
on sera chez lili 19h30 à morial le 23
juillet drogba est de retour au jeu
après quelques semaines d'absence
au même moment il est 23h30 à abidjan
ses partisans s'installe dans un mec un
bar à ciel ouvert il compte 1 les sites
web pour suivre le match des femmes
ivoiriennes espère pas grand chose de
leur idole ce soir là drogba se remet
d'une blessure il n'a pas marqué depuis
deux mois même s' 19e minute
la joie explose en simultané à montréal
et à yopougon le quartier où l'attaquant
unis est considérée comme la plus crue
du la quotidien quand des matinées de
critères de qualité d'image et de la
côte d'ivoire tu veux j'ai bien joué
j'ai décidé de pas automatiquement entre
le connaît finalement drogba compte
trois bus à montréal ce soir là il les
dédie à sa tante décédée trois jours
plus tôt vous n'êtes pas le plus grand
footballeur et dubaï
quand on voit mal à donner quand on voit
messi di pompéo me disait n'est pas ça
mais quand on a la noix la classe de ce
soir c'est un petit at il dit on parle
de temps c'est ça mon fils